si saltarán al azar en cualquier punto
del mar hoy seguramente verían algo así
sin peces grandes sin peces porque los
hemos pescado más rápidamente de lo que
se reproducen hoy quiero proponer una
estrategia para salvar la vida marina y
la idea tiene que ver mucho con la
economía en el 1999 había un pequeño
lugar llamado a cabo pulmo en baja
california méxico que era un desierto
submarino los pescadores estaban
frustrados con no tener suficiente pesca
entonces decidieron hacer algo que nadie
esperaba en vez de pasar más tiempo en
el mar en busca de los últimos peces
decidieron parar de pescar completamente
crearon un parque nacional en el mar una
reserva marina cuando regresamos a cabo
pulmo 10 años después esto es lo que
vimos
lo que había sido un erial submarino se
había convertido en un caleidoscopio de
color y de vida lo vimos volver a su
estado prístino en solamente 10 años
incluyendo el retorno de los grandes
depredadores como los meros los
tiburones los jureles
es guau es un lugar extraordinario si
son buzos vayan a cabo pulmo y aquellos
pescadores visionarios ahora están
ganando más dinero a través del turismo
cuando podemos alinear las necesidades
económicas con la conservación pueden
pasar milagros y hemos visto
recuperaciones similares por todo el
mundo yo me pasé 20 años estudiando los
impactos humanos en el mar
pero ver con mis propios ojos la
regeneración de lugares como cabo pulmo
me dio esperanza por lo que decidí hace
10 años abandonar mi puesto como
profesora en la universidad para dedicar
mi vida a proteger más lugares en el mar
como estos en los últimos 10 años
nuestro equipo de national geographic
christine sis mares cristinos hemos
estado explorando estudiando
documentando los lugares más salvajes
del mar y trabajando con gobiernos para
protegerlos todos estos lugares ya están
protegidos cubriendo una superficie
total del tamaño de la mitad de canadá
estos lugares son los hielos stones los
serengueti del marzo son lugares donde
uno salta en el agua e inmediatamente
está rodeado de tiburones
y esto es bueno esto es bueno porque los
tiburones son un signo de la salud del
ecosistema estos lugares son máquinas
del tiempo que nos enseñan el mar de
hace 500 años de hace mil años pero
también nos muestran cómo podría ser el
mar del futuro porque el mar que una
capacidad extraordinaria de regeneración
hemos visto recuperaciones
impresionantes en solamente unos años lo
que tenemos que hacer es proteger más
lugares que está en el riesgo para que
vuelvan a ser salvajes y llenos de vida
entonces la pregunta es hay manera de
acelerar la protección del mar porque
hoy en día solamente el 2% del mar está
protegido y eso no es suficiente
estudios sugieren que necesitamos al
menos 30 por ciento del mar protegido no
solamente para salvar a la vida marina
sino también a nosotros porque el mar
nos da comida nos da más de la mitad del
oxígeno que respiramos absorbe mucha de
la contaminación de carbono que lanzamos
la atmósfera
necesitamos un
saludable para sobrevivir entonces hay
manera de acelerar esa protección yo
creo que sí y una de las soluciones pasa
por mirar a las aguas internacionales'
los países costeros tiene autoridad
sobre 200 millas náuticas a partir de la
costa todo gira más allá se llaman aguas
internacionales o también altamar en
azul oscuro en este mapa
son dos tercios del océano ningún país
es responsable de la alta mar pero todos
lo son es un poco como el salvaje oeste
hay pasta de todo y nadie controla y hay
dos tipos de pesca principalmente en
alta mar en el fondo y en superficie la
pesca de arrastre de fondo es la
práctica más destructiva del planeta los
super arrastreros los barcos más grandes
del mar tienen redes tan grandes que
pueden contener a una docena de aviones
747 esas redes enormes destrozan todo a
su paso incluyendo corales de
profundidad que viven en montañas
submarinas que pueden tener miles de
años de edad la pesca en superficie se
centra sobre todo en especies que
emigran desde la alta mar hasta las
aguas costeras las aguas de los países
como atunes y tiburones y muchas de esas
especies están amenazadas porque se han
pescado demasiado pero quien las pesca
no quien pesca en alta mar hasta ahora
era difícil saberlo exactamente de los
países han sido un poco transparentes
con respecto a la pesca a larga
distancia
la tecnología satelital nos permite
rastrear a barcos individualmente y esto
es una revolución
y esta es la primera vez que presentamos
los datos que van a ver les voy a
enseñar las rutas de dos barcos pescando
a lo largo de un año utilizando un
sistema automático de posicionamiento
satelital este es un barco pescando atún
y tiburones durante meses alrededor de
la costa sur del continente africano al
cabo unos meses el barco se dirige a
japón para reabastecerse y poco después
aquí está pescando alrededor de
madagascar
este otro barco es un arrastrero ruso
que pesca bacalao en aguas rusas y
también en las aguas internacionales en
el atlántico norte gracias al globo
fishing watch hemos podido rastrear a
más de 3600 barcos de más de 20 países
pescando en alta mar luego si tsinghua
se utiliza posicionamiento satelital e
inteligencia artificial para detectar
automáticamente si un barco está
pescando o navegando y dependiendo del
tipo de movimientos también sabemos qué
tipo de pesca se realiza entonces con un
grupo de colegas internacionales
científicos y economistas decidimos
investigar quién pesca en alta mar y
quién se beneficia mi colega juan
mayorga de la universidad de california
en santa bárbara ha producido mapas
detallados del esfuerzo pesquero
esfuerzo significa cuánto tiempo y
combustible se usa para pescar en cada
punto del mar no tenemos mapas para cada
país que pesca en alta mar china taiwán
japón corea y españa
representan casi el 80% del esfuerzo
pesquero en altamar cuando unimos a
todos los países esto es lo que
obtenemos el mapa global de esfuerzo
pesquero sabemos la identidad de cada
barco en la base de datos por lo que
sabemos la longitud del barco el
tonelaje la potencia de los motores
cuántos tripulantes a bordo con esto
podemos calcular los costos de personal
los costos de combustible etcétera
por lo que por primera vez hemos podido
calcular cuáles son los costos de pescar
en alta mar mientras más oscuro el rojo
más altos los costos colegas de la
universidad de la columbia británica no
se han podido iluminar cuanto está
pescando cada país también sabemos el
precio del pescado cuando sale del barco
combinado con los datos de esfuerzo
hemos podido calcular también por
primera vez las ganancias los ingresos
de la pesca en alta mar tenemos costos y
tenemos ingresos por lo que por primera
vez también hemos podido calcular la
rentabilidad de la pesca en alta mar los
beneficios económicos netos
ahora os voy a enseñar otro mapa los
colores rojos significan que estamos
perdiendo dinero pescando en esa área
del océano los colores azules significan
que la pesca allí es rentable aquí está
parece bastante rentable no
pero hay dos factores importantes que
tenemos que tener en cuenta el primero
es investigaciones recientes han
revelado el uso de trabajos forzados o
esclavitud moderna en altamar compañías
usan esclavitud moderna para reducir
costos para sacar más beneficios en
segundo lugar cada año los gobiernos
subsidian a la pesca de alta mar con más
de 4 mil millones de dólares
volvamos al mapa de los beneficios si
asumiéramos que no hay esclavitud que a
la gente se le paga un salario mínimo y
descontamos los subsidios
gubernamentales de nuestro cálculo el
mapa se convierte en esto
la mitad de la pesca en altamar no es
rentable
de hecho los subsidios son cuatro veces
mayores que los beneficios lo que este
análisis económico nos revela es que
prácticamente la totalidad de la pesca
en alta mar no tiene sentido
qué país que gobierno en su sano juicio
subsidiaria apoyaría a una industria
anclada en la explotación en y
fundamentalmente destructiva y que
tampoco es tan rentable entonces
porque no cerramos
todas las aguas internacionales a la
pesca creemos una reserva marina gigante
en alta mar dos tercios del océano
global estudios de la universidad de
california sugieren que tal reserva
ayudaría a las especies de alta mar que
migran como los atunes y parte de esa
index incremento en la abundancia
ayudaría a repoblar las aguas costeras
de los países y las capturas de esas
especies también se incrementarían así
como los beneficios porque los costos de
la pesca se disminuirían y los peces que
ahora los países grandes están pescando
en el salvaje oeste
los pescarían los países costeros y
bueno y los beneficios ecológicos serían
enormes proporcionar un refugio de dos
tercios del océano para especies de
depredadores como los azules y los
tiburones que son esenciales para la
salud del ecosistema
entonces proteger a altamar las aguas
internacionales tendría beneficios
ecológicos económicos y sociales pero la
verdad es que la mayor parte de las
compañías pesqueras
no les importa el medio ambiente
ganarían más dinero sino pescarán en
altamar
además esto no impediría que pudiéramos
alimentar a la creciente población
humana porque la pesca de altamar
representa solamente el 5 por ciento de
las capturas marinas globales porque
altamar
no es tan productiva como las aguas
costeras
y
las capturas de alta mar se venden como
artículos de alto standing como el
sashimi de tuna
y la sopa de aleta de tiburón las
capturas de alta mar no contribuyen a la
seguridad alimentaria global entonces
cómo vamos a hacer esto cómo vamos a
proteger las aguas internacionales
ahora mismo negociadores en las naciones
unidas están comenzando discusiones para
un nuevo tratado para la conservación en
aguas internacionales pero esto no
debería pasar a puerta cerrada esta es
nuestra gran oportunidad y todos debemos
asegurar que nuestros países van a
apoyar la conservación de las aguas
internacionales hay un precedente en el
2016 24 países y la unión europea
acordaron proteger el mar de ross el
lugar más salvaje de las aguas alrededor
de la antártica lleno de vida salvaje
como orcas focas leopardo pingüinos y
esas incluían naciones pesqueras como
china rusia españa japón pero decidieron
que proteger ese lugar tan único era más
beneficioso que explotarlo
o beneficio ese es exactamente el tipo
de cooperación internacional que vamos a
necesitar lo podemos hacer de nuevo
cien veinte años nuestros hijos se
lanzarán al azar en cualquier lugar del
mar que es lo que verían un desierto
submarino como la mayor parte de nuestro
océano hoy o una abundancia de vida
nuestro legado para el futuro gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]